doubles able to recover
[Applause]
he puts his hand up as a surprise you
just want to get that effort and try to
tip it in
that's a mistake 2.6 seconds ago now
late Griffin will turn
[Applause]
you believe it is again
lightgrip Renault he steps behind
polish culture what a bounce what a
bounce it doesn't have enough trajectory
to go in does it hits the front of the
rim I guess it's his night then old man
his second three of the game is not
official yet Tom Washington takes off
now it's a three-point bastard slippers
well it's official public brasov is
behind the back that came into the
corner - Harvey - to play in the first
pitch hit it's a triple Wow committees
bothered the first for the opportunity
David Platt you gotta let everybody know
this is my shirt it got knocked away
he's regathered in there anxiously
awaiting buzzer-beating an attempt they
better take one Aldridge puts it up oh
thanks
he's been struggling so much he can't
believe that one went down mark
- Billy inside three to twelve yeah
they're four seven on the running going
Griffin
does it get diesel up no problem
go glass no look
lips are starting to run away enter no
hesitation rooms two three Marcus
Aldridge takes the mouthpiece out puts
it right back in the mouth of the Greek
freak LaMarcus Aldridge who is the
big-time Jam early on controls it look
out look out Blake have lost him behind
him between his legs and back and then
just keeps going bye-bye
so now DeAndre has to make them pay at
the foul line
he's 1 for 3 and here he is shooting the
ball for three like he belongs there
kauai goes behind the back up fake 400
of Anthony towns like I said no one with
enough experience to guard him he's
knocking down the outside shot
he shows ding the ball fake and he goes
to work on towns Redick right front of
the Johnston's with 210 enrollee the
shot clock winding down he realizes it
catch and shoot
and even Blake had to smile over that
one oh yeah they can roll with Aldridge
[Music]
[Applause]
live at this time while they just had to
another point on the board
[Applause]
LaMarcus told the state next On January
28 and there's a lot of game left
[Music]
- with the jab off the Jordan mess you
got to find a way to stop the bleeding
and don't give them any momentum
how about Blake Griffin spectacular job
crashing the offensive boards trying to
shake off Robertson was a good defender
I was calling on Ibaka his first
speaking of Popish out you get to travel
and you get to trip sometime and knock
it in there but you exactly right Marvin
under spectacular goal by Redick did he
throw it left-handed as well okay so
here's the past oh it was right-handed
and it was between his own lanes from
the back to the front
that's an amazing class oh he point
shots you know with great shooters that
just doesn't happen back-to-back James
is fine beautiful spin move Plumlee
comes over for help and he just needed
that extra defender and his post two
shot beautiful up and under there check
your seatbelts here we go
Griffin at distance and the wizard Bay
Blake Griffin knocks down a three buck
slippers as state grows sunny with the
wind they will review this to make sure
we got off in time for the red lights
light up around the board he has it
easily in time
the Clippers get the victory by a final
tally and an unbelievable October fuller
they defeat the Portland Trail Blazers
104 to 103 Blake Griffin knocking down
his second three ball of the basketball
game and let the joy began them
he's got great court vision but the
knock on him has been his jump shot
Aldridge four on the shot clock
Marcus comes down the mountain
[Applause]
three point two seconds ago two-point
lead timeout is taken and the Kings can
tie up with a to win it with a three
cigarettes here this one these pagers
yeah and and I'm p.m. pinky right here
it is still too much time left on the
clock
Bree the head alders running the clock
get a timeout
[Applause]
Aldred 16 points six rebounds four
blocked shots
Spurs back within one unlike micro the
size and length of coil inner I think
it's gonna wear him down at the
offensive end my blade he's not even
waiting for the double-team to come over
there's no way that Aaron vanes Simmons
[Music]
to stop him in that situation and they
leave LaMarcus all by himself
lack of communication there by the
Grizzlies and how about the pass by the
way yeah pass that so much of seven
footer Judith will defend for
[Applause]
but this by far was perfect the path by
Chris Paul and aron baynes
split click welcome to your Kodak moment
my friend I mean what a dime here like
Chris Paul but it's all about Blake
Griffin these days
Memphis first everybody as they've
turned it over a seventh time in this
quarter
hammer bust the path so twice he's
trying to make plays and actually just
to mishandle he's pressuring the
basketball but just a perpetual motion
beautiful move by Griffin give Reddick
credit to he came back and sent a back
screen how much better Westbrook is as a
pro than he wasn't coming I guess you
saw him pretty much every game in
college what's the difference
he's learned how to play he's harnessed
that athleticism that he's always had
kadala drives throws attack to McGee
McGee stripped by Ginobili still time
Murray back to Aldrich altered sprout
sit down
Wow and San Antonio up 14 sensational
dunk right here for Aldrich and the
Spurs with fabulous defense as well they
hold Golden State to 16 points after one
in Game one
30:16 columns been quiet comic bothered
by Jordan
Rodimus missed his last six shots
run Griffin just kept running yet people
head and just kept running down the
floor gets ahead of Plumlee
nice pass great finish and right now
nice five by Chris Paul stop running the
whole time we didn't let him get out
ahead of it kids
tegus been into playoff seven
consecutive years
Ginobili straight aways free
rika-chan plus his best rebounding game
against these guys opening night 27
points 13 boards both feed from Griffin
to Jordan what they've discovered the
last two game two turnovers about the
only thing that's gone wrong look at the
ball handling the dish by Blake Kyle
Anderson - Anderson knocked away
[Applause]
he gets the big blocks and then he runs
to the floor and beats half the Atlanta
home fall fall to the rim that's the guy
to just block the shots ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
Griffen Fargo that he's fouled look at
the termination of the face of Blake
Griffin all the time but watch here
enough of messing around you don't call
a foul when I go diving on the floor
then come foul this
[Music]
he's over here appealing to mark I
Autzen Haman Ottman gettin found all
night long
that's big-time right there 779 there
you see no time outs remaining for
Portland
McCallum going straight to the hole
brought by Aldrich LA coming up with the
block ten seconds to go as much of it
was an annihilation he just destroyed
that machine that
not completely forgot that aspect
without slamming up my plate just in
time
lake with some vengeance Aldridge eight
on the shot clock
get physical with
Sauvage who the [ __ ]
play first off he's not gonna pay a lot
Robbie with Jefferson years
Jefferson with the pressure on the left
side on the near side
they go to play crisp ahead and clear
out wheels inside with the hook got it
and it's tied with point 9 the rafters
don't have any timeouts remaining me
hook he does this so beautifully now
remember you got a 6/8 Guayana shot
clock at two Aldridge has to fire I'll
be sensitive what the shot clock
expiring
clothing out warriors offensive trip for
the Spurs but no it's Sunday
clearly the Bank is open no Daniels with
a rebound Jackson were taken to the
river on the other end
no we won't bite 20 now first Blake with
the block
[Music]
[Applause]
the pumps throughout Lopez just a
beautiful ball fake there and then go
tops he'll bounce topside to Blake
Griffin turns drives
I cannot get away off to Dallas
[Music]
[Applause]
Marcus Blake works the baseline gets to
the basket reverse placer could count
that baby and a foul he had to put on
this ball because he releases it when
he's underneath the basket but there's
your English you look to what he had to
do and he did it it's got a touch event
herder comes up with wide open is start
off yeah it's dead one in LaMarcus going
out to that block you push it the
opposite direction the marsh sucks in
the entire defense and Derek point two
on the break
[Music]
outside but by Anna's turns buyers with
a triple with 2.6 seconds to play go
look now but the Pistons have a
two-point lead
since leads a rocket 98-96 a clutch
triple for Blake Griffin this was a
running ahead and looked I thought did
somebody get a touch on it or was it the
board and now onwards balls decide Blake
Griffin of the Pistons back
[Music]
that's all school right there for Blake
to take it my goodness is he shot the
ball what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content